[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is the Polish language or
yen's ik Polsky as it's called in Polish
polish is the official language of the
Central European country of Poland where
97% of the population speaks it as a
native language that makes Poland the
most linguistically homogeneous country
in Europe it's the second most widely
spoken Slavic language after Russian
with around 45 million native speakers
and an additional 5 million second
language speakers as you may know Slavic
languages are a branch of the
indo-european language family between
the Year 500 CE II and 1000 CE II proto
Slavic gradually diverged into dialect
and by 1000 CE II that were already
distinct West Slavic East Slavic and
South Slavic languages and dialects of
these three languages developed into the
languages of each Slavic branch the West
Slavic languages include polish Czech
Slovak
sorbian a minority language in eastern
Germany and kashubian a minority
language in Poland Poland first became a
state in the 10th century around the
time that Slovak was developing into
various distinct languages the
unification of various Slavic tribes
within one Polish state helped tie their
dialects together as a single language
the Christianization of Poland took
place in the decades following the
creation of the Polish state and along
with that came Latin via the Roman
Catholic Church which became the formal
written language and the language of the
nobility polish continued to be the
predominant spoken language among the
general population but Latin certainly
had some influence on polish because of
its prestigious position polish was not
a written language until the adoption of
Christianity and the arrival of Latin
from that point on vernacular polish
began to be written informally using the
Latin alphabet
the oldest sample of written polish that
we know of is a list of names dating
back to the year 11:36 the oldest
written polish sentence that we know of
dates back to 12 70
there are more substantial texts from
the 14th century onwards as polish
became more commonly written from the
beginnings the Latin alphabet was
insufficient for writing all the
different sounds of Polish so over times
polish writers began using a variety of
diacritics that have become part of the
polish alphabet and a characteristic
part of Polish writing during the
Jagiellonian dynasty polish became an
official language alongside latin also
during this time cities were founded and
administered under a German system of
law known as mock d'abord law due to the
influence of this system of law numerous
German words entered polish German
loanwords in Polish include Arab douche
meaning town council and boredom east
meaning mayor also there had always been
contact with Germanic speakers
especially in the northwestern areas all
the way back to proto Slovak so there
are other Germanic loanwords in Polish
that go back a long way
Latin remained an official language
alongside polish through the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth but
polish had gradually become more widely
used by the nobility than latin in the
sixteenth century while polish was
becoming more standardised it served as
the vehicle for the Golden Age of Polish
literature it also became the lingua
franca throughout much of Central and
Eastern Europe spoken by the ruling
classes not only in Lithuania but also
in Ukraine and Belarus which were mostly
part of the Commonwealth at the time the
third official language of the
Commonwealth was ruthenian which was
spoken in the eastern areas and would
later develop into Ukrainian and
Belarusian dialects polish was
influenced by ruthenian to some extent
due to contact Poland was erased from
the map between 795 in 1918 after being
partitioned between the Russian Empire
Austria and the Kingdom of Prussia and
later the German Empire which it was a
part of Polish ceased to be an official
language anywhere and dialectal
differences grew in the different
occupied parts of Poland after the first
world war the borders of Europe were
redrawn and an independent Polish State
was restored lands which were considered
historically Polish were taken back from
occupying powers but not all lands
the borders were once again redrawn
after World War two with the recovered
territories being given from Germany to
Poland and the Soviet Union occupying
eastern areas and making them part of
Belarus and Ukraine many poles were
forcibly transferred from those
neighboring countries to Poland
transferred being a euphemism for kicked
out this forced transfer of poles from
their homes to different dialect areas
resulted in dialect levelling the loss
of dialectal differences and transfer in
other words expulsion of non poles to
neighboring countries made Poland a very
linguistically homogeneous country today
four main dialects of Polish are usually
recognized but the differences are now
slight there is greater polish lesser
polish masovia and Silesian those
speakers often consider themselves a
separate language community and
sometimes counted is kashubian which is
generally considered a separate language
but is closely related to Polish so what
is polish like pronunciation and
orthography polish writing has a number
of characteristic features that are
quite striking at first glance the
polish alphabet has 32 letters but there
are also seven digraphs pairs of letters
which represent individual sounds notice
that 4 of those digraphs feature the
letter Z this makes Z the most common
letter in Polish writing and notice that
there are two additional letters that
are derived from Z which appear in
another two digraphs if you include
those people seeing polish in writing
for the first time we'll definitely
notice the abundance of Z's and Z like
letters but those two z derived letters
are not the only special letters in
Polish there are 9 in total this letter
is pronounced whoa
while in Polish the letter W is normally
pronounced these letters represent nasal
vowels
more specifically vowels followed by
nasal semivowels the exact quality of
the nasal sound varies depending on the
surrounding sounds and the nasal sound
is normally absent before work or in the
nasal F at the end of a word for example
this word is normally pronounced Chev
and is only pronounced like this shall
in very careful formal speech
there are some noticeably long consonant
clusters in polish this one has a
cluster of five consonants in a row
buzzers Glendon meaning ruthless then
there's this one
tres temps four meaning crime it has a
cluster of only four consonants but
there's also a digraph in this first
cluster which makes it appear to have
three consonants instead of two so to
someone looking at Polish for the first
time it probably appears to be full of
long consonant clusters even though some
of them are just digraphs most simple
polish consonants are pronounced like
their English equivalents but note that
C is pronounced as sir and as I
mentioned before w is pronounced though
and also note that the letters X V and Q
are not used in Polish the sound exa
usually represented by X in English is
spelled KS in Polish one important
feature of Polish pronunciation is hard
and soft consonants a common feature of
Slavic languages soft consonants are
generally palatalized like a hard
consonant pronounced together with a Y
sound
aside from you and LA which are always
soft soft consonants are indicated by an
accent above the letter or by an eye
following the consonant for example sir
and xie na and na pas and piya
most of the digraphs we saw before
belong to a subset of hard consonants
that derived from historically soft
consonants why do hard and soft
consonants matter because in Polish some
inflectional suffixes are different
depending on whether they are preceded
by a hard consonant or a soft consonant
most consonants specifically obstruents
stops affricates and fricatives when
they appear in consonant clusters must
all be voiced or voiceless
this results in voiced obstruents
becoming voiceless when they come before
or after a voiceless consonant for
example fiat Otsuka this also happens at
the ends of words this word meaning car
some ahout and this word meaning dr.
lett cash this type of D voicing is one
of the main things that keeps Polish
from being a fully phonetic language in
other words a language in which one
grapheme equals one sound another thing
is that the distinct
between a few sounds has been lost so
that now these letters are pronounced
the same grammar let's start with the
word order of Polish the unmarked or
neutral word order in Polish is SVO as
in English for example Moya Jets quests
Katya
meaning my child is cute or my child is
sweet the word order here is exactly
like in English subject verb complement
the sentence has no object but the
adjective here is a compliment another
example mesh is Ania opiate which means
the man is eating dinner
subject-verb-object notice that there is
no definite article in Polish and
actually there isn't an indefinite
article either now this is the unmarked
or neutral word order but polish word
order is quite flexible and elements of
the sentence can be moved in order to
emphasize them in the first sentence we
could emphasize my child by moving it to
the end
so what K is Tamiya Jets car in the
second sentence we could emphasize man
by moving it to the end o BRT image is
now so this sentence is now dinner eat
the man technically any word order is
possible though some sound unnatural and
would be most suitable for written
poetry or something how can these words
be moved around freely like this doesn't
that get confusing the main reason is
that Polish is a highly inflected
language and nouns among other words
have case endings endings that tell us
the function of the word in the sentence
because the function of the word is
obvious from its ending and we don't
need to use word order or syntax to
determine the function of the word Jet's
Co means child this is the singular form
in the nominative case which is usually
used for the subject of a sentence or a
predicate adjective after a linking verb
there are six other cases in Polish
genitive dative accusative instrumental
located and Vaca t'v these are the
singular forms but there are also plural
forms it's important to note that polish
has grammatical gender Jet's Co is a
neuter noun in their most basic form the
nominative form nutri nouns end in a M
uh or uma
there are also masculine and feminine
nouns masculine nouns in their non
to form usually end in a consonant an
example is co-op Bach meaning boy some
case endings differ between different
types of masculine nouns compare co-op
back a masculine person to Bank a
masculine object notice there's a
difference in the accusative plural the
endings are different for masculine
people on the one hand and masculine
objects and animals on the other for
many nouns this is also true for the
nominative plural also notice that the
genitive and accusative singular endings
are different in these cases the endings
are different for masculine animate
nouns in other words humans and animals
on the one hand and inanimate objects on
the other though in the genitive case a
few types of nouns are exceptions
feminine nouns in their nominative form
usually end in aa or a a for example
matka meaning mother adjectives also
agree with nouns in gender number and
case and they have their own sets of
endings for example mordom Attica means
a young mother in the nominative case
but here's a phrase in the genitive case
Jetts como de maitake the young mothers
child not only the noun has a genitive
case ending but so does the adjective
and notice that the adjectives genitive
ending is different from the nouns
adjectives have endings for all cases in
all genders for both singular and plural
verbs polish verbs have two tenses past
and non past but there are also two
major aspects which indicate completion
of an action the perfective aspect or
incompletion of an action the
imperfective aspect each verb has
separate infinitives for the
imperfective and perfective aspect and
then conjugations are built around those
infinitives in order to indicate the
tense in other words the time at which
the complete or incomplete action is
done let's take a look at the verb
meaning to read to touch this is an
imperfect of infinitive in other words
the reading is in progress or ongoing
such a touch this is a perfective
infinitive meaning the reading is
complete the perfective form of verbs is
derived from the imperfecta form by
adding a prefix to it or sometimes by
adding a suffix or changing a vowel in
the verb stem now let's conjugate these
in the past tense you drop the Chuck
from the end of the infinitive and add
one of these endings to the remaining
stem for example Yap to Talam means I
was reading in other words the reading
was ongoing at a certain point in the
past
Hyup such a tau M means I read in other
words I completed the action of reading
within a certain time period in the past
by the way please note that Polish is a
pro dropped language meaning that the
subject pronoun can often be left out
that's because the verb endings often
make it clear who the subject is but
something to note is how the verbs are
conjugated for gender in the past tense
in the first and second person singular
there are masculine and feminine forms
the third person singular also has a
neuter form for the plural forms the
distinction is between masculine
personal endings in other words for
people and all the others a masculine
inanimate object or animal will be
conjugated the same as for feminine or
neuter nouns so while a man would say
yeah to Tao him a woman would say yeah
to Talam and if you're talking to a man
you would say did cheetah wish but if
you're talking to a woman you would say
did cheetah wash speakers of other
Slavic languages won't see anything
strange about this but speakers of
Germanic and Romance languages might
need to get used to this now let's take
a look at the non past conjugations non
past what do you mean by non past is it
present or future well that depends on
whether it's imperfective or perfective
for an imperfective verb like to touch
the non past conjugation has present
tense meaning for a perfective verb like
such a touch the non past conjugation
has future tense meaning all-night
reduction Chaka this means she's reading
a book while this sentence on Upchurch
attacks on Chaka means she will read a
book unlike the past tense conjugations
the non past conjugations don't have any
gender distinctions the tricky thing
about the non past conjugation is that
there isn't just one of them there are
actually four different conjugations
with virtually all verbs following one
of them conjugation 1 and conjugation
for are characterized by an avowal in
the 3rd person singular form conjugation
to buy an I vowel in the 3rd person
singular form in conjugation 3 by
a vowel in the third-person singular the
perfective non past form is sometimes
referred to as the simple future there's
another compound future tense that
expresses the imperfecta future in other
words an action that is ongoing or
repeating in the future Amna banjo
Chatuchak shaka this sentence means she
will be reading a book it's formed by
using the future tense of [ __ ] the word
meaning to be followed by the
imperfective infinitive [ __ ] is an
irregular verb using a different verb
stem in the past present and future
forms here's an example in the present
tense is tempo lakum this means I'm not
polish and as a quick side note here we
see how polish negation works you simply
place the negation particle yeah before
the verb now that we've examined some of
the major features of Polish let's take
a look at a few more sentences and see
what we find this sentence means my
father reads 2 books every day we are
each it's a generated detection scheme
word-for-word it's my father everyday
read 2 books first off we see a
possessive adjectives before the noun
meaning father possessive adjectives in
Polish are inflected for the gender and
number of the nel here the word all each
its meaning father is masculine and
singular so the possessive is in it's
masculine singular form and a chet's is
in the nominative case next so Jenna is
an adverb meaning everyday the word for
day is genu next we see the third-person
masculine singular present tense form of
the verb next we see the number davia
which means 2 numbers 1 to 4 in Polish
have different forms depending on the
case and gender of the noun they are
referring to
davia is feminine and is used for
nominative and accusative case here it's
the accusative the number is feminine
because the word for book is feminine
Chomsky is the plural form used for
nominative and accusative cases and here
it's the accusative a moment ago I
mentioned that numbers 1 to 4 have
different numerous forms numbers higher
than 4 have only two forms when counting
masculine personal nouns they are in the
genitive case and the nouns they refer
to our in the genitive case and when
counting all other nouns they are in the
nomina
of accusative case but the noun is still
in the genitive case so if we change the
number in this sentence say from two to
five the sentence would look like this
my father reads five books every day
Moya cheats sojanet rita P&G on Jack the
number five has two forms being Jew for
masculine people and PNG for all others
including objects like books Jean
Jacques in this noun is in the genitive
plural form and one more sentence this
sentence means everyone likes him
because he often laughs she's single
ljubljana botanist oh sheesh me word for
word it's everyone him they like because
often reflexive pronoun laughs first we
see the pronoun meaning everyone
pronouns in Polish have different case
forms since this is the subject of the
sentence it's in the nominative case
next we see a personal pronoun meaning
him personal pronouns also have
different case forms this one is in the
accusative case there are two other
accusative forms yet gah gah gah gah is
used when the pronoun is not being
emphasized Lybian is the third-person
plural form of the verb Lubitsch meaning
to like this verb belongs to conjugation
too and has an I vowel in the
third-person singular
next we see ba a conjunction meaning
because and after that we see Johnston
an adverb meaning often next we see a
reflexive verb meaning he laughs polish
has lots of reflexive verbs meaning that
both the doer and the receiver of the
action are the same that may not always
be obvious in terms of meaning but in
terms of grammar that's how it works
this word share is a reflexive pronoun
which you simply add to the verb to form
the reflexive it has only one form
finally something simple in Polish the
verb here is in the third-person
singular present tense and this verb
belongs to conjugation one let me take
this part of the sentence and ask a
question about it chief trysts ago Lu Bo
meaning does everyone like him the way
you ask yes or no questions in Polish is
very simple you simply add the question
marker chair let's formulate another
question this means who do they like
cagonu beyond this is an open-ended
question using an interrogative pronoun
meaning
interrogative pronouns in Polish have
different case forms this one is in the
accusative case in the nominative case
it takes a different form so if you
wanted to ask who likes him it would be
toggle OB da is the nominative form
Honorable Mention this is a last-minute
addition to the video but several Polish
speakers have asked me to include this
particular feature of the language when
talking about the presence of something
in Polish you use the verb [ __ ] meaning
to be for example on twist means he is
here that seems straightforward the
unusual part is the negative form niyama
goto not it has him here so this is like
saying it doesn't have him here but who
is it
I don't know but I suppose it's like a
dummy subject in English like when we
say it's sunny
it doesn't really refer to anything as
you can see polish is an extremely
interesting language but it's also one
that many learners find daunting and
intimidating but as with any language
there are people who learn it whether
they move to Poland or they're simply
deeply interested in Polish culture
those people didn't learn everything
about the language all at once they
learned certain pieces first then they
learned other pieces afterwards until
eventually they had a fuller picture of
the language so don't let the details of
Polish scare you off if you have the
interest and the motivation to go for it
the question of the day to native
speakers of Polish what additional
features of Polish would you like to
tell us about for example are there any
features of informal speech that you
would like to share and to students of
Polish what do you find most challenging
about the language do you have any tips
on how to deal with it if you enjoyed
this video then please check out the
various length okis social media
accounts and of course as always I want
to give a very special thanks to my
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen who are my top
tier patreon supporters so I want to say
a very special thanks to them for their
support and to everyone thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]